des semaines de pression soutenue sur un
système déjà fragilisés l'été a été
désastreux pour les hôpitaux ontariens
où la pénurie de main d'oeuvre a forcé
la fermeture sporadiques de plusieurs
urgences et résonnant
après avoir nié que la province
traverser une crise le gouvernement food
se ravise
et présente un plan en cinq étapes pour
réduire la pression sur les hôpitaux
étape 1 continuer de lutter contre la
coved 19 étape 2 augmenter le nombre de
patients en soins de longue durée étape
3 réduire le temps d'attenté pour les
chirurgies
étape 4 améliorer la couverture médicale
dans les régions rurales et la dernière
étape recruter davantage de personnel
on ne peut plus accepter le statut cours
affirme la ministre de la santé qui
promet que sa stratégie permettra
d'embaucher 6000 travailleurs de la
santé libéré 2510 dans les hôpitaux la
galerie qui fera votre iphone de
l'opposition elle a plus de gouvernement
datée blir le réseau public car pour
réduire la pression sur les hôpitaux le
gouvernement folle financera les
opérations dans les cliniques privées
n'ont jamais aucune foi
si le nom privatisations et des
reproches aux conservateurs de ne pas
avoir été transparents sur leurs
intentions pendant la dernière campagne
électorale
costaud que tu privatise c'est des
ressources publiques ne sont plus
disponibles le gouvernement rétorque
qu'il s'agit d'une solution nécessaire
et promet que les ontariens ne vont
jamais besoin d'une carte de crédit pour
accéder à des soins de santé
une promesse qui n'a pas su rassurer le
milieu de la santé aux aînés nous nous
opposons à toute tentative de privatiser
le réseau de la santé a déclaré
l'association des infirmières autorisées
de l'ontario
cette infirmière n'est pas forcément
contre la privatisation
elle demande toutefois des précisions de
la part du gouvernement
climatisation ou non le temps presse
pour stopper l'exode du personnel après
des années de pandémie qui auront mis le
réseau de la santé avait des preuves et
si les cas de covin baisse la pression
sur le gouvernement elle ne cesse
d'augmenter et si le média radio canada
toronto